With about 11,000,000 open job roles in the United States alone,
organizations are struggling to find qualified candidates at a pace that's fast enough.
And with the growth in social media and other publicly available personal data,
it's difficult to address bias in the hiring process.
So let's tackle these issues by addressing two key questions.
First, how can you find candidates who have the right skills for your job opening and your business?
And second, how can you connect with these candidates in a quick and more streamlined way?
Well, don't worry, because this is where IBM and ThisWay Global come in.
IBM Watson Orchestrate and ThisWay Global combine the power of your Watson Orchestrate digital employee, or "digey",
with ThisWay Global's diversity sourcing and matching engine.
So you can find qualified candidates from a diverse talent pool.
Here's how it works.
First, let's find qualified candidates for the job.
In this case, the job descriptions reside in Box.
Just select the job you need to hire for, and your digey connects with ThisWay Global's candidate sourcing technology
to provide you with potentially hundreds of matches.
You can also filter for specific locations.
Here we're pulling candidates from Denver, Colorado through ThisWay Global's Discover Service.
Once you have your list, you can easily save the file for future reference.
Now you can contact the candidates you selected using the saved data.
Let's encourage them to apply for the opportunity.
Note that the email comes from your email address so the message is less likely to be flagged by spam filters.
You can even use custom templates and personalize for your audience.
Your digey curates and sends the email to your selected candidates, including a link to apply.
That was fast and easy, right?
But what about increasing the diversity of your talent pool?
Traditional hiring processes can include the evaluation of candidates based on their social profiles.
This can trigger conscious and unconscious bias
- maybe caused by something as simple as someone's picture or name.
ThisWay's technology empowers your digey to surface diverse candidates by redacting data that may influence biased decisions.
Here, check out how potential bias is redacted from the resume screening process.
This is key to delivering diverse and qualified candidates.
So to wrap this up,
Watson Orchestrate and ThisWay Global combine the value of digeys with an engine that can help you increase the diversity of your talent pool
and identify qualified candidates.
You get assistance from your digey to find qualified candidates with the right skills for the role,
A streamlined way to contact candidates,
and most importantly, knowing you've helped to reduce bias during the hiring process.
Thanks for watching.
To learn more, please click on the link.